snaking the worst thing to ever happen
to Call of Duty has finally been G what
the is this piece of snaking is a lame
ass movement technique that involves
spamming the Crouch button so you go
from prone to standing pretty much
instantly making you hard to shoot in
short it's cheap and it sucks oh my God
this game is hilarious oh my God but you
might be asking what does it mean to be
GA now GA refers to a gentle 's
agreement a player pack to essentially
bar something from competitive Play When
a Dev can't or won't but for a long time
players couldn't agree to GA snaking
because many believed it would lead to
an even worse mechanic finally though
after a podcast of all things an
impromptu vote was held and Pros
actually agreed to ban it let's just
hope for everyone's sake it actually
sticks